hi everyone I am mayank and welcome to
this fantastic video on top 5 cyber
security certification for 2024. by
simply learn but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these type of videos and
find them interesting subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so let's get started
picture and employee at her computer
working with data
in a background a hacker secretly access
her companies or his company's
confidentials files he or she steals
sensitive information and sells it to
criminals who then hold the company
ransom for a profit
it sound like something Auto movie but
unfortunately it's a common occurrence
in today's online landscape this is why
cyber security has become such a vital
part of any business strategy and cyber
security Specialists are in demand now
more than ever let me show you some
fascinating strategic with you that
illustrate the impact and potential of
cyber security before we delve into the
fascinating cyber world according to
Glassdoor the average salary of a cyber
security engineer is one hundred thirty
thousand dollars in the US and in India
it's seven lakh per annum
learning AI offers numerous benefits
ranging from career opportunities and
Innovations to personal growth and
ethical consideration it equips with
your valuable skills and knowledge that
can have a profound impact on a various
aspect of society and the World At Large
but choosing the right course to excel
in the field of cyber security can be
challenging with so many option
available out there in the market how do
you know which one is the right for you
well we are here to help you without any
further Ado let's discuss the top 5
cyber security certification for 2024.
number one on the list is post graduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with MIT University this
project program in cyber security is
designed to equip with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
this cyber Security Programs aims to
help you stay ahead of all the latest
Trend in the cyber security as well
this course will help you learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you will get foundational to
Advanced skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
the program this project program in
cyber security includes cyber security
technology application and policy from
mitscc this program leverages mit's
academic excellence in cyber security
and provides comprehensive understanding
of the field to ensure your Readiness
for the industry you will also engage in
multiple projects allowing you to hone
your skills and emerge as an exceptional
cyber security professional for
admission to this postgraduate program
in cyber security candidates should have
a bachelor degree with an average of 50
or higher grades have a non-programming
back now not required to have a priority
Works experience so join now seats are
feeling fast the course link is in the
description box below number two on the
list is triple it Bangalore Advanced
executive program in cyber security
become an industry ready professional
with an advanced executive program in
cyber security and transform your career
in six months this course provides a
high engagement learning experience with
real world application and is designed
for individuals who want to start a new
more fulfilling career this Advanced
executive program in cyber security will
help you develop expertise in defensive
cyber security application security
malware analysis ethical hacking and
many others in partnership with triple
it Bangalore and npci the cyber security
program provide you with a deep
understanding of needed to support the
opportunity for disruption in cyber
security industry after completing the
course simply Learners have made
successful career transition boosted
career growth and got average healthy
cycle of 70 and maximum salary hike of
150 percent
so why to join this program so why
triple it Bangalore Advantage virtual
internship with npci integrated Labs
career mentorship for admission to this
postgraduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a better degree
with an average 50 percent or higher
grades have a non-programming background
are not required to have private work
experience so join now seats are filling
fast the course link is in the
description box below number third on
the list is cyber security expert master
program the cyber security expert master
program will equip with the skills
needed to become an expert in this
rapidly growing domain you will learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure including securing
data and information running risk
analysis and mitigation architecting
cloud-based security achieving
compliance and much more with this Best
in Class program simply learn cyber
security expert master program provides
cyber security professional with
foundational level intermediate level
and advanced level skills that entail
industry leading certification like com
Tia Security Plus chcism C issp and ccsp
the program begins with industry level
technology training then progresses to
intermediate level hacking techniques
such as reverse engineering and network
penetration testing this course will
enable you to stay up to date with the
latest cyber security news and Trends
and then make sure our implementing
etiquette cyber security measures in
your organization using suitable
hardware and software so join now seats
are feeling fast the course link is in
the description box below number fourth
on the list is
IIT kanpur professional certificate
program in cyber security that team
boost your career as a cyber security
expert through this cyber security
program in collaboration with IIT kanpur
in just six months you will learn
Advanced offensive cyber security
strategies to protect networks and data
from breaches theft attacks and more
professional certificate program in
cyber security red team empowers you
with a skill set to analyze the threat
landscape and create strategies to
ensure system stability and security
must essential cyber security skills
through Hands-On training in real world
cases simply learns professional
certificate program and cyber security
at Team leverages IIT kanpur academic
excellence in cyber security and
equipped with students with key skills
through a unique applied learning
approach this programs provide you with
the necessary skills to leverage
offensive cyber security to strengthen
the stability and security of ID system
you will benefit from and be better able
to master the highly sought after cyber
security capabilities owning to the
comprehensive curriculum of the program
to gain admission to this program
candidate should have a bachelor degree
in a related field basic knowledge of
programming and sophisticated two plus
years of work experience before so join
now seats are filling fast the course
link is in the description box below the
last one on the list is
cehp12 certified ethical hacking course
learning Advanced processes in ch study
at ethical hacking course in this online
ethical hacking certification training
you will love Master Advanced Network
packet analysis and system penetration
testing techniques to build your network
security skill set and prevent hackers
you will get access to certified expert
professionals who will guide you
throughout your Learning Journey simply
learn CES certification course provides
these hands-on experience required to
master the techniques hackers leverage
to penetrate Network system and 45 5
year against it this certified ethical
hacking course is aligned with the
latest CH v12 by the e-council and with
adequately prepare you to scale your
skills this ethical hacking
certification verifies the skills
required to thrive in information
security domain many IIT departments
have made CH compulsory for security
related post CES certified ethical
hacker professional on 44 higher
salaries than non-certified Professor
this ethical hacking certification needs
learner need to possess an undergraduate
degree or a high school diploma in any
discipline as may be prevalent and
accepted in their respective country of
residence and or work so join now seats
are filling fast the course link is in
the description box below with that we
have come to end of this video on top 5
cyber security certification I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any question about the topics
covered in this video in the comment box
below our team of expert assist you and
endorsing your problem thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign